how big of a role does your age play
when it comes out to entrepreneurship
think about that that is probably one of
the most common questions I get asked
all the time on snapchat on Facebook on
cyberdust on Twitter Pat I'm 18 years
old how old do I need to be to be an
entrepreneur hey Pat do you think I can
still be a stronger entrepreneur I'm
only this age I'm only that age what is
a good age so today I want us to process
if you can be a good entrepreneur and a
successful entrepreneur being young
whatever age you are and what are real
benefits of being an older entrepreneurs
as a younger entrepreneur and then at
the end I'll give you some of the
stereotypes younger entrepreneurs yeah
that's gonna be your enemy if you're
watching as you're younger your enemy is
going to be these few things I talked to
you about and it will go from there so
here's what it is an owner entrepreneur
versus a younger entrepreneurs that's
age really matter older people are
typically more paranoid that helps some
business because when you're older
people have stolen from your life to you
giving you some deals that didn't go
through a bad partnership a bad
relationship so your paranoia's hire
typically helps some business when
you're younger you're more naive
you-you-you think there's you know a
world is a great place you still believe
world peace exists and everything can be
Nirvana and utopia exists all this stuff
so not not fully I'm not saying
everybody because there are some kids
that grew up in some you know some
cities if you grew up in Boston and LA
and South Side Chicago if you grew up in
some places New York Bronx some some
places you grew up and you're gonna
learn about being bullied and pushed
around so you'll have that but generally
younger is gonna be more naive all
there's gonna be wiser they've had more
mistakes they've seen things young
there's gonna be they think they know it
all right they think they know
everything totally fine stay with me
although they're they have more contacts
younger it's really only family friends
and teachers but older they have a lot
more contact older is more logical
younger is more emotional oh there's
more lots to lose so the decision-making
process is different younger to have
nothing to lose right so when you ask
the question who is more capable you got
to look at these cup
things a model but there's a lot more
things I can add to this is I just want
to keep this video very very simple but
I want to I want you to think about it
in a completely opposite way so right
now the way we're explaining it it's
more beneficial to be older and be an
entrepreneur right well is it really
because think about this there is some
level of naive naiveness that's actually
not bad for business why because there's
a certain level of you know optimism to
think that people are going to help you
so you're willing to ask people for help
where this person's like oh they'll
never help us or they won't be
interested or they will want to do
anything you're not no they will help us
why wouldn't they help us of course it
loves to team up who wouldn't want to do
something like this that's the childlike
night nests that's necessary for
business while disperses wiser and you
think you know it all right the younger
generation may think they know it all
you know what sometimes these younger
people they think they know everything
is it really that they think they know
everything or is it really something
that they think everything is possible
because I don't think it's really
younger generation thinks they know it
all they just think it's more possible
now this notion we always hear about is
what they think they know it all they're
clueless their kids their district no no
no what you're really saying is you
don't believe it's possible and they
think it's possible maybe the older
entrepreneurs and the older generation
needs a little bit more a possibility
thinking and they inject into us right
maximum contact they have more leverage
for contact you don't have that many
contacts that part is absolutely true
however however all the people again are
more reluctant to asking for help and
younger are younger don't care by the
way if you're watching this right now
and you are under the age of twenty
three twenty four twenty five and you
have teachers professors coaches that
like you family members uncles who like
you let me tell you what script will
work for you pretty much sixty seventy
percent of the time you
ready I need your help done deal I need
your help auntie I need your help
mom I need your help dad I need your
help hey coach I need your help
hey teacher I need your help hey you
know counselor I need your help
hey you played such a big role in my
life I need your help your best friend's
parents who really like you always they
always like you I need your help auntie
can you help me out with this I'm trying
to be an entrepreneur and I'm trying to
be a business I really need your help
can you introduce me to this person here
hey I really am serious about wanting to
do this I'm gonna make an impact with my
life I need your help keep using that
script because it works in your
advantage you all them people get they
don't need help I know what I'm doing I
don't need anybody's help it is a very
very very big mistake in business when
people no longer want ask for help next
logic emotion you know what sells
emotion sells now you got to definitely
be looking at the logical size of
business contract and all that other
stuff but emotion sells emotional speaks
here logic speaks here okay
opportunities sometimes everything they
go through I'm gonna look at the numbers
numbers of all this stuff yes logic like
for instance if you're dealing with a
venture capital and you're dealing with
money people they don't care about how
emotional you are about your store so
you also got to know your audience you
know purely logical what is the highest
possibility of building some kid what's
the numbers what if this grows what if
that grows okay everyone will give you
quarter million bucks at ten percent
first round whatever that's that's how
they'll work so donation is don't expect
these seasoned investors to be too
emotional with you they're not but
there's a lot of benefits and being
emotional next nothing to lose nothing
to lose lots to lose just so you know
this is your edge this is your age if
you're watching this this is a very big
edge when you have nothing to lose who
is the scariest person to fight in
streets the person that's got two kids
and a wife or the person has got nothing
there by themselves nothing to lose
who does the CIA hire by the way think
about that what is the pedigree of the
people CIA and the FBI like to hire do
you know what it is you know what it is
not married not good with parents
or parents are dead no siblings no kids
no nothing why there is no ties you have
nothing to lose so you make a better CIA
agent you make a better FBI agent why
because of that the world of
entrepreneurship is similar if you know
sometimes some people that have all have
a house I have this I can't lose all
this stuff what if you do lose all this
stuff now what if you do end up losing
all this stuff that's their challenge
this is not your challenge now if you're
watching this in your same path so whose
side are you taking I'm not taking
anyone's side I'm simply being an
attorney for them if I'm representing
them and I'm simply being an attorney
for them if I'm representing them I'm
not taking sides I'm just telling you
what your leverage is here now I will
tell you the younger and the older
entrepreneurs here that are watching
this when people ask this age matter I
want you to know something I don't care
if like the other day I was listening to
this kid play piano 10 years old oh my
gosh he played piano and I'm listening
to this kid
it was insane how he played a piano I
couldn't believe how it played a piano
now keep a money um three and a half
times his age but he's 10 years old
playing the piano does age matter in the
world of piano know has nothing to do
with anything so if somebody wanted to
teach the other person about playing the
piano who's gonna teach you the 10 year
old teaches me why is that so let's just
dissect that allele that's break that
down a little bit
why age and time in service again time
and service not age what does that mean
she's been playing the piano for six
years I've never played the piano she's
the expert I'm not she teaches me I
listen okay I listen not the other way
around I listen to what she's telling me
it doesn't matter how old I am I don't
even know how to read the keys on on the
piano she's gonna be able to teach me
she's the expert the same exact
principle goes in a world of business so
if you're younger if you're 14 15 16 17
18 19 20 to whatever the ages between
between 14 and 25 I don't care what age
you are if you're younger these it a
couple things you got to keep in mind
number one your criticism you get for
the younger generation is a lack of
discipline it's like a discipline so you
got to work on your discipline they
typically have more discipline because a
lot more is on the line you typically
have less discipline because not a lot
is on the line to you if it doesn't work
out it doesn't work out so I as the
customer need to be able to trust your
discipline that you're going to come
through and you're going to deliver and
you're serious about it you're not just
going to go home and fool around with it
so I watched discipline number two
number two is going to be delivery if
you say you're gonna deliver deliver on
time if you're gonna say you gonna
deliver on whatever promises yep deliver
on it don't just say deliver on its
memory memory remember things remember
things to have an edge next product
knowledge know everything about whatever
you're selling know everything about
whatever you're selling everything
whatever you can immerse yourself in
that product just absolutely get obsess
about learning every single thing about
the product history stories fact stats
everything you can about the product
again I don't care what it is every
single thing about that product you
immerse yourself in so when you come in
you talk to me about your product and I
say god knows what he's talking about
that's very impressive so here's what I
wanted to done wanna help I can do this
for you sir and I can do it for you for
this much money I thought that thought
that I here's my contract let me just
take all my contractors my contractors
through my adopt my papa we're doing
this business
great no problem I see discipline I see
product competency I see their respect I
see someone that's behave in the proper
way
no problem great let's do business okay
no problem great let's do business Anna
last but not least which is one of the
biggest criticism the younger generation
gets to is what laziness the younger
generation doesn't know about hard work
maybe they're right so guess what you
should do should work very hard their
younger generation they're so lazy they
know nothing about hard work I remember
when I was their age I had 17 different
jobs you know all those stories
here about a part of it is right maybe
they were more hard-working than today
because today there's social minute
there's a lot more distraction so if
you're watching this and you're say you
know my dad would always said this and
I'm 18 years old my dad is 44 years old
I'm so sick and tired of hearing that
for my death well there's a part of what
your dad is saying that is right there
was no Facebook there was no Twitter
there was barely internet so you mean
there was not mean we we did still
listen to music on tapes it's not crazy
you've probably never seen a Walkman in
your life before we grew up we didn't
have phones this would if you had a cell
phone you had to be wealthy to have a
cell phone not everybody had a cell
phone it wasn't something that everybody
has had a cell phone with them so what
is that what do I mean by that here's
what I mean by them work double time
work triple time outwork anybody that's
a competitor you outwork them anybody
that you're competitive out put them and
once you do that no one's gonna ask you
how old you are I'm sorry how are you 19
years old I don't do business with
anybody below 25 no one says that one's
gonna say that they're not thinking in
their mind how old you and their mind
they're thinking how much do you know
will you deliver will you keep your word
are you hard-working do you know
everything about this product let's do
business that's all they care about you
fit those few needs and you have this in
your favor you got an edge on the other
marketplace who is also trying to become
an entrepreneur and build a business for
themselves and take away your market
that should have clients away from you
but you gotta play to your strengths you
do that you got a shot at being an
entrepreneur so with that being said
we're trying to get to a hundred
thousand subs I think right now we're on
seventy-five thousand subs if you have
not subscribed to this channel please be
sure to do so click on a link below here
to subscribe to you trying to find a
pillow and subscribe to the channel and
if you got any questions thoughts
comments you can always we go let's see
if I can catch it one-handed
did you see that was some random ass
type of stuff right there dude where cut
the ball and if I was about to start so
although Randy Moss is not playing
anymore
ok so subscribe to this channel if you
haven't yet this channel will get 2
million subs but our next major
milestone is to get to a hundred
thousand steps and we have some major
plans to tee
sharpen oars all over the world about
how to build a business for yourself
around the world from 196 countries
follow this channel here so subscribe if
you got any questions comments comment
on the bottom if you're not following me
on snapchat either and you want to ask
me questions a lot easier for me to also
snap back you can always follow me on
snapchat let's put my code up there bet
David 19 is the name username and then
this is what my snapchat code is you can
follow me right there with that being
said thanks for watching everybody take
care bye